and good evening from Washington we're
gonna get right to it tonight a first
lady double standard that's the focus of
tonight's angle
she's gracious she's generous and she's
beautiful inside and out
so if Melania Trump were a liberal it
would be a non-stop love fest from the
media but since she's married to
President Trump it's a very different
story the first lady's shoes remember
they were wrong during hurricane relief
remember they mocked her accent in her
recitation of the Lord's Prayer before a
rally and now get this according to some
in the media
she can't even decorate the White House
for Christmas properly let's recall by
the way how Michelle Obama was treated
when she rolled out her White House
decorations
next stop the Red Room festooned with
cranberries and fruit trees for
Christmas alone we're going to have more
than 90,000 people come through these
doors how many hands do you shake at
Christmas tree Oh thousands thousands
tell me how you do it without getting a
you know me but I mean I love that but
you guys I'd almost do so many firsts in
the White House I remember the Chicago
sun-times the first time you all came to
the White House was just big front-page
story with you in the red dress
the first time you spend the night at
the White House the first cabinet
meeting at the White House what's your
favorite first gosh that's a good
question Christmas this this is
Christmas beautiful and I've never
visited the White House during Christmas
and it is just absolutely magical they
are managing a star she can sell
magazines simply by being on the cover
she can sell sweaters simply by putting
them on
she's a striking harvard-educated lawyer
who can hold her own next to anyone okay
I just that is great it's great it's
great to go back and remember right if
it was her arm she cares it was
everything was great about Michelle
Michelle Obama cover of Vogue how many
times 20 times
and so basically you'd swear that
Michelle christmastime walked on eggnog
but when Melania Trump unveiled this
year's spectacular White House Christmas
decorations
Vanity Fair went on the attack this
nasty columnist I've never heard of her
name Kenzie Bryan suggested that the
first lady had finally made herself
productive this is what she said is it
safe to assume that we have some clarity
as to what she's been up to when she's
not traversing the Great Wall of China
or making an appearance at Turkey
parting ceremony maybe it's funny how by
the way little concern they had for what
Michelle Obama was up to when she was
jetting all over the globe
and hosting private parties at the White
House with all a Hollywood glitterati I
mean every other weekend it was like
celebration time in the White House
where she was carting her children all
over the place and a Harry Potter movie
sets locking down Broadway every time
she and Barack had date night it was all
great all at the taxpayer expense I can
go on and on and on but it's nearly
Christmas so back to Melania the first
lady made one of the most elegant
entrances I frankly have ever seen at a
White House Christmas decoration preview
Shoji descended the Truman staircase as
ballet dancers performed in the Great
Hall looked like it was the Nutcracker
performance itself and even that was
ridiculed Vanity Fair this time actually
put words in the first lady's mouth
writing quote adequately done she
probably whispered to the principal
dancer I only counted four mistakes and
that fun online some are comparing
nighttime images of the Christmas
decorations to a total nightmare
Wow these all the memes you know the
White Witch of Narnia it's all up there
but you know what a real nightmare is
it's the double standard that has become
so obvious so routine and apparently so
acceptable we're conservative women are
concerned the only acceptable real
authentic woman in the media landscape
today is a liberal woman a progressive
one and if you're not you're just too
dumb you're too stupid
you know the difference and remember
what these two first lady said this
morning I'm concerned he voted against
Hillary Clinton voted against their own
voice in a way they will be under
tremendous pressure and I'm talking
principally about white women tremendous
pressure from fathers and husbands and
boyfriends and and male employers not to
vote for the girl
oh right Hillary we're all damsels in
distress and you're just you know
Joan of Arc well long ago these icons of
the left and others sounded the dog
whistled that it was okay to trash
conservative women and their media
lackeys followed orders it's disgraceful
that a White House garden planted and
maintained by the park surface service
was celebrated for years in the media as
a veritable Garden of Eden because it
was dreamt up by Michelle Obama but when
a conservative first lady decorates the
White House spends time with DC
schoolchildren she is accused of
exploiting them and was savaged for her
wardrobe what happened to women being
able to choose whatever they want to
wear whenever they want to wear it
they're always pro-choice when it comes
to aborting babies but ninki you now
can't choose what you want to wear it's
AG larynx double standard it has to end
it's so obvious leave the first lady
alone and just enjoy the decorations
it's Christmastime which may well be the
most beautiful series of decorations I
have ever seen at the White House and
that's the angle